hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
selections from the anthropologist Ruth
Benedict's article anthropology and the
abnormal are often anthologized as a
defense of ethical relativism and in it
Benedict is arguing for a type of
ethical relativism that we typically
call cultural relativism which says that
what is wrong or what is right what is
good or what is bad what is affirmed as
as ethically valuable or as the opposite
is going to vary from culture to culture
in such a way that there really is
nothing that you can say cuts across
every single culture in a way as to
provide an absolute ethical norm instead
what she is saying is that different
cultures provide different you might say
codes or matrices however you want to
think about it
she doesn't tie yourself to any
particular language here and those
determine what the people within that
culture view as right or wrong good or
bad just or unjust pick whatever other
moral language that
you like now she does acknowledge an
incredible diversity of human beings as
individuals within cultures but the
culture provides a sort of framework in
which they have to find their place or
perhaps not find their place and be
considered abnormal she's going to frame
this in terms of the categories of
normality and abnormality not to say
that every culture uses those terms of
course but she says that our modern
Western culture at least within you know
more or less advanced literate civilized
areas tends now to think of those as the
most important terms and she also
cautions she says modern civilization
from the point of view that we have
becomes not a necessary pinnacle of
human achievement bought a lot one entry
in a long series of possible adjustments
she views civilizations cultures however
you want to think of about them
societies as being akin to languages
which use a common phonemic manifold
that is the apparatus that we are given
as human beings which is really quite
remarkable in its own respect but they
they play upon it differently so that
some languages will not in fact use
certain sounds or they may differentiate
things in ways that we don't distinguish
as in for example Mandarin where you
know the place the location within the
mouth for what would in it for an
English speaker be the same sound like
juror it means a different sound it
signifies something different and you
can say the same thing for cultures she
also thinks they're like languages and
that they develop over time without
anybody saying AHA we want to do exactly
this or even when they do make
deliberate decisions about that it
becomes just part of the process and so
she talks as many anthropologists will
do
about custom and habit as being
established
she thinks that normality and
abnormality are in fact culturally
defined and determined and so if we
frame it in terms of abnormality and
normality or deviancy is another term
that she uses for abnormality then we
are going to arrive at the point where
we can see this in a relativistic way so
she says here about halfway through
every society beginning with some
inclination in one direction or another
carries its preference farther and
farther integrating itself more and more
completely on this basis discarding
those types of behaviors that are
uncongenial and so convert the most
valued traits of our normal individuals
in our society been looked on and
differently organized cultures as
aberrant normality she says in short
within a very wide range is culturally
defined it is primarily a term for the
socially elaborated segments of human
behavior in any culture and abnormality
a term for that
the segment that particular civilization
does not use they they don't like that
doesn't mean that people won't show up
within that segment but they're viewed
as being outside they're viewed as being
wrong as deviant as as sometimes you
know objects of fear or anger or
derision she says here we go
we don't make the mistake any longer of
deriving the morality of our locality
and decade directly from the inevitable
constitution of human nature we don't
elevate it to the dignity of a first
principle obviously she's not speaking
for everybody in modern Western culture
but she is speaking for a certain group
she says we recognize that morality
differs in every society and as a
convenient term for what for socially
approved habits so this is a very clear
relativistic standpoint viewing morality
or ethics or however you want to put it
as simply what has become
established and approved within a given
social framework which means that it's
relative to that social framework she
goes on and says mankind has always
preferred to say it is a morally good
thing rather than it is habitual and the
fact of this preference is matter enough
for a critical science of ethics but
historically the two phases the phrases
are synonymous so that here's where she
says the concept of the normal is
properly a variant of the concept of the
good it is that which society has
approved a normal action is one which
falls well within the limits of expected
behavior its variability is a function
of the variability of behavior patterns
and it can never be wholly divorced from
a consideration of culturally
institutionalized types of behavior so
what is good from this standpoint will
vary from place to place from location
to location and most importantly since
you can take people out of their place
by culture by the set of assumptions and
practices and shared meanings that
define a particular people culture
Society well however you want to frame
it so cultures then determine what
personality traits or what actions what
motives
what explanatory accounts people give of
their behaviors what desires and
everything else that falls into the
moral range could be objects could be
books which of those count as normal and
which count as abnormal so she grants
that there are going to be a lot of
variants and she brings up examples of
people who actually don't fit into other
cultures one thing that we should
mention as a side note is Benedict does
not assume at all that every culture is
you know because it's got its own
thing is always in harmony with itself
as opposed to us modern Westerners who
have lost our roots or anything like
that every single culture is facing the
same basic problem which is that it's
got a code and some people because of
their nature because of quirks about
their their experiences some people fit
solidly into that other people are on
the outside and then there's mechanisms
by which they get people on one side or
another indoctrination catechesis
modeling you know modifying people's
behavior until you know they they fake
it till they make and all of those are
possibilities and the anguish that that
human beings often feel when they don't
sense themselves as fitting into the
normal that occurs in her view in
practically every culture as well so
every culture has you know some sort of
manifold you might say and then human
beings have this variability some of
them are more outgoing some of them are
more reflective some of them are more
risk-averse we could go on and on and on
about these different traits or
complexes the cultures themselves tend
to favor some of these at the expense of
others and every culture according to
her does this so she gives several
examples of these traits she says every
culture is more or less an elaborate
working out of the potentialities of the
segment it has chosen insofar as the
civilization is well integrated and
consistent within itself it will tend to
carry farther and farther according to
its nature its initial impulse towards a
particular type of action so cultures
are understood as dynamic and as
developmental she says from the point of
view of any other culture these
elaborations will include more and more
extreme and aberrant traits notice from
the perspective of outsiders who have
their own culture the continual ongoing
development of this
culture is going to seem aberrant we
might use as an example the development
of music you know you could think of sub
genres of different kinds of rock and
then think of heavy metal and then think
of the development from the 90s
really onward of all the many different
genres of metal so that for some people
heavy metal doesn't signify classic
1970s 80s heavy metal or the bands
influenced by that but signifies perhaps
Scandinavian death metal some some very
small niche where people are always
trying to go further and further and
further right even within the the normal
in this case realm of traditional heavy
metal there was an ongoing development
you know the introduction of distortion
pedals instead of having to achieve
distortion by putting you know your
guitar closer to the amp and having it
over driven right you can hear a
difference between 1970s and 1980s metal
within the same band all right
so these provide us with easy to
understand examples and you can
elaborate your own examples using
contemporary instances as well provided
you can think about how a culture could
could develop itself further she talks
about four cultures and four sets of
practices motivational structures
however you want to think about them
that tie in with normality and
abnormality and deviancy comparing them
to Western culture and then comparing
them to some degree against each other
she talks very briefly about transfer
nomina and cata lapses going into a kind
of a somnolent state and she says that
within our society we regard that as
quite a buret if somebody is just
staring off into space we interrupt them
and ask them what are you thinking about
but in India where this is actually a
integral part of the culture not only
because of
religious and philosophical practices
but because of daily day-in sort of
things going on and because it's also
part of a developmental structure you
know in in early years you're supposed
to be oriented towards things of the
world in later years you're supposed to
be oriented towards liberation towards
human development well then in that case
that could be normal behavior and not
cause anyone to bat an eye she also
talks about something that's been
changing to some degree can you know
quite a bit in our own culture
homosexuality at the time that she's
writing it's viewed as deeply aberrant
and we've seen this changing within many
segments of modern society for example
homosexuality no longer being treated by
the psychiatric establishment as a
disorder but rather as something that
that's available for people that moved
out of a Burin see or abnormality in to
normality at least in some areas and
other points though the clock is
swinging back the example that she
brings up about a culture that actually
incorporates this and allows for
different orientations to be developed
in some respect fits what we now you
know would call homosexuality but it
also fits into the entire notion of
gender and being transgendered because
she talks about the bear - conception
which is found in some American Indian
tribes she talks about men women who
were men at puberty or thereafter took
the dress and occupations or met men who
at puberty or thereafter took the dress
and occupations of women sometimes they
married other men and lived with them
sometimes they were men with no
inversion persons of weak sexual
endowment who chose this role to avoid
the jeers of the women the bird ashes
were never regarded as first-rate
supernatural powers as similar men women
were in Siberia but rather as leaders in
women act
patience good healers in certain
diseases or among certain tribes as the
genial organizers of Social Affairs and
here's the key point that she's saying
in any case they were socially placed
they were not left exposed to the
conflicts that visit the deviant who is
excluded from participation in the
recognized patterns of his society there
was a place for this person if you had
certain you know bents or behaviors
somebody could say well maybe you're
over here and that's okay right so in
our society until very recently that
would not have been okay and even in
large parts of our contemporary modern
society there are many people who feel
that that's not okay as well she brings
up another example from Melanesia where
paranoiac tendencies are taken to an
extreme that we would probably consider
to be mental illness but for the people
there that's considered rationality and
our over trusting genial behavior would
be viewed as a form of deviancy she
talks about here we go a society built
on traits that we regard as beyond the
border of paranoia in this tribe the exo
gammak group says marrying outside of
their their group look upon each other
as prime manipulators of black magic so
that one marry is always into an enemy
group which remains for life ones deadly
and unappeasable foes they look upon a
good garden crop as a confession of
theft everyone is engaged in making
magic to induce into their garden the
productiveness of their neighbors
therefore no secrecy in the island is so
rigidly insisted on as the secrecy of a
man's harvesting of his yams their
preoccupation with poisoning as constant
no woman ever leaves her cooking pot for
a moment unattended even the great
Affinia economic exchanges that are
characteristic of this Melanesian
culture are quite altered in dough boo
since they are incompatible with his
fear and his trust that pervades the
culture and she actually talks about a
deviant there a person who from birth on
adopt this paranoiac structure and
behaved friends in a friendly way in a
charitable way to their neighbors and
they reviewed as somebody you know
totally wrongheaded whereas we would
look at that as as being quite affable
she talks also about the tribes in in
the American Northwest and some of the
strange murderous as we would call it
behavior that that comes about because
of that and she says well you know
within their culture that actually makes
some sense
she says among the Kwakiutl it did not
matter whether a relative had died in
bed of disease or the hand of an enemy
in either case death was an affront an
insult to be wiped out by the death of
another person the fact that one had
been caused to mourn was proof that one
had been put upon very you know strange
perspective from our part and as she
points out a strange perspective from
the part of other Native American tribes
so she brings up the fact that somebody
from a Plains Indian tribe who would not
retaliate for example if his wife was
taken from him would be looked at as an
idiot by these other tribes he would be
viewed as the deviant whereas he would
have a hard time understanding their
hyper-aggressive 'ti and willingness to
seemingly take offense about anything
it's at the point where they would kill
people so all of these are ways of
elaborating culture and if if Benedict
is correct in her views then good or bad
right or wrong would in fact be
dependent on what is considered normal
or abnormal in cultures and there
wouldn't be any one single overarching
culture that would determine that even
if there are you know disciplines such
as anthropology coming largely out of
the
a modern West that would only be one
perspective among others
you